foreign
[Laughter]
well uh yeah good to see you man Jazz
Fest New Orleans oh I saw the pictures
yes we must be drunk guy we did shrooms
we drank we danced the night away you
know you go to a music festival yeah
crack that split that little ball oh I
love the ball it's like a spray paint I
love it yeah mine's for my tagging days
did you tag oh man we used to go around
and really look like a skater boy I
can't ride a bike you think I'm skating
I'll see you later boy all right what
happened to her she transitioned no I
just assumed her she had a tie I bet
she's still I bet she's still big
you think yeah I don't know I think she
came and went yeah we'll see what do you
got is she in rehab now that's her today
I bet she's still young too I bet she
was like an 18 year old pop star she
seemed like one of those yeah how old is
she now if she's younger than us she'll
help me go oh she's definitely younger
than us but once the pedophiles you get
too old they stop listening you lose
your demo
um but yeah Jazz Fest so
I want to trash one guy and praise one
guy Bring It On All Right 38 years old
oh wow she is older than you younger
than me
um
so it's good lineup Lumineers dead and
co uh Ludacris uh lizzo Ed Sheeran a lot
of bangers a lot of Heavy Hitters
no pun intended with the lizzo but
I want to see John bat John Baptiste
yeah he's he's great right unreal from
New Orleans local
so it was Ludacris and John Baptiste at
the same time so she wanted to see
ludicrous you know he's famous he's a
big name he was a classic I mean here's
some hits too what was it beer and
chicken wasn't that the album move [__]
get out the way I got hoes in different
area codes yeah that's a classic classic
but
yeah I don't want to trash the guy too
hard but he totally phoned it in really
because he did area he opens with area
codes and he goes here we are in the 514
and it's the 504. so the whole crowd
just goes all right this guy is just
getting a paycheck so he kind of he kind
of phoned it in and also rap we were
talking rap it's not great live He's
just kind of that's not that's not
always true that's not I start to leave
live once oh it was amazing yeah full
band
yeah it was aha that helps he was just
up there alone
it's kind of like stand up you're like
this sucks but but Jean-Baptiste had his
full High School orchestra he had the
marching band he had a gospel choir and
he had like a dance team on stage and it
was Unreal it was like a powerful
Transcendence so you went to sway me
into going to Baptista was she easily
sways she never heard of him so she's
like we're leaving this famous guy to
see this guy I've never heard of Michael
he's a local he's killer he plays like
nine instruments she was like all right
all right
best thing she ever did she was moved
she was up on her feet hooting and
hollering I mean it was incredible damn
you know what when a song is like the
whole crowd it feels like one unit it
was like an energy it wasn't it was
moving really something I love good live
music
and also I met him once briefly did you
meet him when he did Colbert he was cool
super cool super nice yeah I wish I
could talk to him a little more but uh
yeah yeah you know classic my parents
they're like you're doing Colbert you
know because they're obsessed with New
Orleans like John Baptiste does the uh
the band leader I'm like yes yes can we
get back to me yeah that's how they are
yeah but there he is that was the show
look he's wearing his high school uh
t-shirt
oh it was really something damn
I mean the whole place is going nuts
it was really something the marching
band everybody's sweating yeah it feels
very New Orleans too the colors and oh
yeah yeah purple and gold
oh it was really just you know when you
because I'm not a dancer you're not a
dancer but when you have that for
yourself oh okay what a fine dancer I'd
like to see lately I'm in there
somewhere but uh isn't it weird when you
when you are at a wedding or something
and just one of your friends starts
dancing you're like you can dance I know
it's like Ryan Hamilton he can move I'm
like this dude can [__] dance twinkle
to Joe list can dance
no can you can shake away really yeah
he's a stiff honky I'm shocked yeah we
can't I don't even try though I don't I
think a lot of it's just like believing
in yourself enough to try and we don't
believe in ourselves no and you got to
let go we can't let go we're too busy
observing I can't like Let it Loose but
during that I was letting it loose and
plus I was on drugs and drunk that helps
yeah but it's hard to be like look at
that jerk off and then you do it and
you're like yeah I'm worse and it's a
lot of there's not one attractive person
in New Orleans so everybody's fat and
gross and in tank tops and Crocs and
they're just you know doing this [__] so
you don't feel as weird when you when
you do when I do my finger guns and my
white guy's [__] but it was really
something you do the finger guns in
Texas they shoot back be careful open
carry yeah
um but at one point John Batiste he was
like jamming rocking out jumping up and
down and he goes stop stop stop he goes
guys I need more from you I need more
and the crowd was like oh [__] and then
he kicked it back up and we all went
crazy yeah there was a bunch of stiff
Whitey yeah but I was like man I wish I
could do that I had a show Once a woman
said to me during sex I need more oh my
God
uh yeah that's that's actually I mean
we've done that I guess we have done
that I'd do it the seller still I'm like
guys come on I followed a comment here
then I did all crowd work and I'm going
first it was like a fall a Fallout spot
I was like I forgot to call and I was
like just give me anything you have yeah
you going after someone does all crowd
work I'm like guys come on yeah came
here in the rain there's nothing worse
than having a media yogurt set and then
leaving in the rain yes you're like what
is a [__] cliched movie it's so true
is going on because on the way to the
show you're like I'm gonna get a
standing oh I'm gonna try that new bit
that new bit's gonna open up another
five minutes of new stuff I'm Gonna Be
In the Zone and then it's like guy doing
crowd work she's talking they're not
listening at your reality really sets in
let me make sure our guest is coming oh
she's a little
classic Rosie O'Donnell damn
I'd love to get Rosie I just re-watched
her on curb really oh man League of
Their Own oh yeah all the way may she
was hot damn uh Madonna oh yeah yeah but
would you would you steal Madonna yeah
have you seen that Meme going around
Madonna is Whoever thought Madonna would
be less hot than Roseanne
and it they put them side by side and
it's true I [__] Roseanne I think
wow look at Rosie trying to be hot yikes
that's gonna haunt my dreams
sure thin then yeah I guess so
that's what like they would consider fat
back in the day that's true isn't it
yeah she was a fat lady like she was
like the fat punchline but she's not
that big no no that just says how much
we've changed the society we are now
fatter than this and now this looks thin
that works out for women though but you
know what's crazy is like you watch a
sitcom from the 80s or 90s 90 of the
jokes are fat and gay jokes oh 100 it's
insane you watch I tried to the critics
one of my favorites and I rewatched all
the time but it's like man I'm like wow
I forgot how many of these jokes are
just fat jokes yeah yeah friends got in
trouble for fat being fat phobic and all
that it's all Monica was fat that's
every other joke and she wasn't even
actually fat no but they were like fat
suit things they were fat suits yeah you
know oh yeah man Madonna was so sexy
back in the day but look at her now
God what up
it's like a she looks like a like an
allergic reaction that's what plastic
surgery does to you yeah she got stung
by a bunch of bees yeah yeah you know
what's weird is like if you're a kid and
you're like one day if I do anything to
one day of sex with Madonna and then you
grow up and this is Madonna yeah yeah
now do the Roseanne side by side if you
have a Genie in the Genie's like you get
to have sex with Madonna and this is the
Madonna you're like [__] I know the gym
can I do a wish over yeah the Genie's
like all right I'll give you Madonna 20
23. no is there another Madonna is she
the only Madonna
is there another person in history named
Madonna yes Lady Madonna though this is
yeah uh oh not his mother I thought it
was Mary Mary Magdalene
oh [__] how awful is this the Madonna is
Mary Matt no it's not it's his mother
right I don't know Mary that's Mary
yeah mother Mary if only we had
something to Google this
is Mary's nickname
what they didn't have nicknames in the
before Christ times
oh boy
but they have the Madonna syndrome which
is when you can't be attracted to people
you like which I have what do you mean
if I'm into you I can't get it up really
yeah yeah but if I if you're just some
throw away one one and done bam wham bam
thank you ma'am I'm a porn star how's
marriage working out for you not great I
have to pretend to not know her it helps
it does help like when someone's a rude
[__] to me I'm kind of like wow
it really there's that Seinfeld episode
remember Jerry's girlfriend is so rude
to George yes
totally relate to that totally I mean
how much porn now is just like you piece
of [__] and I'm like yes I am a piece of
[__] right I I yeah I've had women Turn
Me On by accident just by being cruel
whoa cruel I don't like you like crew I
like cruel cruel but like rude okay what
do you what give me an example uh well I
like the rude the rude works like shut
up you idiot I'm like oh God reminds me
my mom more like of a tease I guess I
mean like a rude like if a woman just
like slammed a door in my face I
wouldn't be like I need to [__] her
right like you know hmm it says here no
I'm With You Madonna mistress complex is
the inability to maintain a sexual
arousal within a committed loving
relationship there you go I have that
but knowing I have that makes it helps
me what do you do no games or something
uh
no I think I think I just toss her
around a little bit to a wig on ever
yeah wig yeah we got wigs what color are
we talking about we got blonde we got uh
cornrows we got black face you name it
we do what we got to do but the cornrows
in the black face are for you yeah yeah
yeah oh man
she likes what I mean to her so it kind
of works out because I don't think I'm a
mean guy so I can be mean yeah and now
it feels like I'm it's it's not me yeah
it's kind of I found out women do like a
man who's a little you know dominating
yo for sure you know they don't like a
guy who's like they want you to be like
get your [__] ass yeah I never do
that sound again but uh a guy they want
a guy who's like you know like a Don
Draper type yes yeah well it's like the
Chris Rock joke excuse me uh Mrs uh
could you lick my balls ha lick your own
balls so you gotta have some Authority
but she likes it she likes it mean so
you know it takes me out of it a little
bit and then I can get hard and also
when you're getting blown it's hard to
not get it up it's also hard to be mean
while you're getting blown true she's
sucking your dick you're like yeah you
suck that dick [__] and she's like what
the hell sorry well you know these Wall
Street guys they they dominate all day
they're dealing with clients they're
yelling on the phone so then they want
their balls stomped on I think women all
day people open the door for him they go
how are you ma'am ladies first so then
they want a little mistreatment the ball
stomping I totally agree I mean it's
like the opening scene on billions when
he's literally he's getting pissed on
yeah it's like what are you that's the
opposite of his life these politicians
but the ball stomping never spoke to me
it seems like a bit of a stretch of
course what about the ball stomping's
gone wrong oh what if that goes wrong
you're both stomped now you got one ball
yeah very easy for that to go wrong sure
especially if she's wearing high heels
oh oh my God you get a little you get an
impaled testicle I'm not in any pain I
don't like a lip bite I don't like I
don't even like to scratch there's
enough pain in life yes I you know it's
gonna be unpredictable pain why are we
why are we writing out pain and it's
gonna burn when I pee after this anyway
how about the people who are in like a
lit like put a cigarette out on you what
the hell is that nah how easy is your
life that you're that you're asking for
extracurricular pain good point good
point I'm with you yeah they got it too
good yeah well same with the Cutters oh
I was always attracted to the Cutters in
high school really yeah because they
were damn they were they wouldn't end
their life so I'd have to worry about
like a suicide I don't think but they
were damaged enough to like need
attention I was like I'll save her I'll
save the girl cuts herself yeah and then
I date her and they'd be like this is
worse
this is worse than the cutting black
community have an expression for that
it's called Captain Save A Hoe oh think
if you're trying to save a woman from
her circumstances you're the hero but
you're not really great name for a cheap
gardening store you gotta come down to
Save A Hoe save money on hoes sounds
like a shitty rum Captain Save a hub
yo ho Blow The Man Down
sorry
Save A Hoe Captain Save A Hoe man
where's that Marvel movie
I want Captain Save A home still with
Brie Larson
it's uh uh yeah man there's a more like
cheddar Larson all right what's going on
with with what is that the the need to
save it's a very weird thing yeah I
think I still have it yeah yeah I don't
have this need to save I I get the one
to like me but the save maybe if you
save them from a circumstance they're
indebted to you and they'll stay with
you and won't leave you that's a great
Point that's probably it yeah a little a
little Salamanca therapy for us today
but what about the girl who doesn't like
you you get her to like you now you
don't like her
yeah it was that easy yeah right he
hated me then I spun it around and now
you like me I'm just like Ugh exactly
it's like a video game but if it's too
easy you're done with it yeah you know
you don't want to keep playing you want
a challenge yeah if it's hard you play
that thing every night and try to beat
it like her
did you guys see this uh Trump clip I'm
changing it what is it uh this is when
he was in the deposition on the uh rape
allegations and uh he Carol e whatever
her name is uh brought against him about
raping the 80s what I didn't know that
he met this woman at Bergdorf they went
in the back room he forced himself on
her according to her story oh yeah I've
heard of this yeah and uh she was on TV
a bunch wasn't she yeah during the last
election really yeah so anyways he was
Depot on this and they brought up the
you know who loves this story is a Saks
Fifth Avenue
and they brought up the uh the Access
Hollywood tape and they're like do you
really think that I should just play
this do you really think you can grab
women by the [__] and then he just does
nothing for his own defense here let's
say something let's hear it I just
started kissing them it's like a magnet
just kiss I don't even wait and when
you're a star they let you do it you can
do anything grab them by the [__] you
can do anything that's what you said
correct well historically that's true
with stars
ah Superstars that they can grab women
whoa well that's
dude's in a rape case and he's defending
what it's if you look over the last
million years I guess that's been
largely true not always but largely true
the last million years is a long way
yeah that's a big it was cool million
years ago yeah well that's that's the
funny thing about progress you know
right
you know it was you know what's cool uh
150 years ago slavery
some shit's changed yeah the last
million years you could grab a
Triceratops by the [__] like how far
are we back are we going here we just
gotta love him for like staying true to
who he is it's like yeah I said this
I'll double down on it even during my
own rape trial he does not flinch and
also hearing someone else read it it's
kind of funny yeah like man his voice is
really uh I mean we hear someone else
reading that oh it's like when you go
into casting right you're doing an
audition and they just they're like
lifelessly reading this script that's
what it felt like yeah wait so what does
he say oh yeah but
let's see
it's not in his DNA to say I should not
have done that of course okay you think
Melania is ever like this hurt my
feelings and he's like I'm really sorry
that made you feel that no chance it's
not in his DNA you can't do it can't do
it I think you can say that yeah and
now you said
before
a couple of minutes ago that this was
just locker room talk
and so does that mean that he didn't
really mean it
no it's locker room talk I don't know
it's just the way she's trying to get
one out okay
wow he's not figuring that out though I
thought he had another line where he was
like she's not my type anyway yeah do
you want to see that well if it's funny
also I've been a decent amount of locker
rooms in my life I've never had people
be like it's rape he was rape though no
you I mean look we are a little more
vulgar when we're just sure man I went
to an old boys school we're a little
more vulgar yeah a lot of farting and uh
what do you call it dick chicken and you
do say some [__] about women that you
would not say to women obviously but but
when you're just like yeah you rape
that's locker room so that's [__]
insane yeah
you were just referring to I think so
yes so part also is defense publicly not
here he said she's not my type I would
never which is pretty disgusting but
whatever I'm not passing judgment uh and
so he's shown this picture
and I'm gonna ask you is this the photo
that you were just referring to I think
so yes and do you recall when you first
saw this photo
at some point during the process I saw
that's uh I guess her husband John
Johnson who
was an anchor
for ABC nice guy I thought I mean I
don't know him but I thought he was
pretty good at what he did
um here it comes I don't even know who
the woman let's say I don't know who
it's Marla
I don't know her but I know he said this
is Marlon Maples in the photo yeah and I
I didn't know Carol it's the other woman
that he got sure so he's saying my type
is not Gene Carroll yet he confused her
with Marla wow I mean your whole case is
done there I don't get it
not my type but Marla was his ex-wife uh
oh okay I didn't know that the woman who
was raped with his ex-wife he was like
this is Marla in this photo but it was
actually the accuser interesting
now what does that mean
that's more yeah it's it's my wife which
one woman are you pointing each other no
here
Felix died
he's out of Adderall
and the person the woman on the anyway I
thought that was pretty stunning
interesting maybe I was too drugged out
I missed all this he was uh it's amazing
that he was president and he doesn't
drink coffee
or beer isn't that weird I mean Diet
Coke that's what he that's where he gets
his caffeine that's like not a good
caffeine no Diet Coke sneaky bad for you
oh I don't even know if it's Sneaky
anymore I think it was sneaky back in
the day yeah because if we all thought
it was healthy ooh look at me Diet Coke
but now it's aspartame and all this
other [__] NutraSweet yeah
Colin Quinn I don't know Diet Coke like
four a day and I don't think that helped
him yeah damn yeah it's not good no also
you rarely see a Diet Coke drinker and
you're like you look really healthy
that's true it's never like a Duo I'm
like that dude shredded and he said
what's your secret Diet Coke all right
no you look like [__] usually okay is
she here
hey all right I need to know if I need
to switch to No guest mode or guest mode
what do you mean well if it's no guest
I'll turn it up and then we'll do our
show but if we have a guess I'll turn it
up and do her show and you'll
no we're good to go all right
times you turned it up I turn it up in
different ways I can turn up the heat
turn up the cold turn on the fan okay
turn on the the defrost you name it I
know what I think that means very
confused I don't either I was talking
out of my ass I don't want to leave you
hanging as Carlin said to you you got a
real talent for jacking around hey
let's see again
[Music]
yes I'm late in many ways I'm 18 weeks
later were you at a writer strike thing
uh no I didn't I have not been picketing
well no I have I have I've been
picketing twice a week like we're
supposed to oh okay cool uh we got an
out anyway yeah yeah no
um I I showed up there and there was
like a lady there with like an 11 day
old kid and I was like oh I have to be
here oh way to ruin it lady no I was
like you're making the rest you must
look so bad this is the one time we have
an excuse yeah you know anyway I am how
are you guys mother of the year hey good
good I mean uh thanks for making I know
you're of course thanks for having me
I'm stuck I'm psyched psyched is there
kind of something with the strike where
you're like hey we got some time off uh
100 okay oh yeah I like the second that
I heard the news I I booked two tickets
to Mexico whoa oh good for you the
second I heard I was like where are you
going uh we leave on Thursday hell yeah
yeah we're gonna go to Cancun for a
couple days then I'm taking my mom to
Italy I'm really kind of I'm just
amazing I'm kind of really you're hoping
this is not resolved it's like covered
without the virus I want it resolved but
I'm not if they're like oh it's resolved
but AI is gonna write all the scripts
and you guys have to punch them up I'm
gonna be like that's fine
are we making more money is that like an
actual thing that people are talking
about at this oh yeah yeah it's coming
right I don't think it's insane I mean
what do you mean what's in what part of
it is insane I mean they first came for
the cashiers and now they're like
watching Frasier Pilots like we could do
this that's pretty crazy yeah that part
of it I I'm like because people are like
oh that's insane
some people you think they're like oh
this is we're overthinking this we're
worrying about this too soon but I don't
think it's I think it's a real change
wouldn't it make more sense for the for
the AI to do the CEO job though because
that's all algorithmic and that's like
what 55 million dollars as opposed to
what writers get paid it's a really good
point yeah it's a really good point it
doesn't matter yeah because they have
the money so they won't you need to
overthrow not really cut that part out
I'm probably gonna do another special
there especially coming out soon Elon
came out and was like you guys like they
have to stop the AI they have to stop I
saw that didn't he yeah he's totally
against it so that means that
technically I guess they could take over
for CEOs like that's well maybe Elon
goodbye artificial intelligence and then
it will crash and we'll be okay yeah
well the head of Google's like this is
bad yeah he's the head of Google and
you're like oh so it's bad now that
you're 78 and a multi-multi-billionaire
right now since you invented this thing
you're like oh this is bad but I'll keep
the money right and didn't he take off
he took off now he's done yeah yeah he's
like he's like right before the [__]
he's he lit the [__] match yes threw
it on the house and just walks out yeah
exactly what a piece of garbage but who
knows I I think we still got like five
years before it can really do on some
some zingers well how many how many jobs
by the way veter sent me a joke and he
searched uh a joke in Gary veter his
voice for AI and Sam morel's voice Ai
and they're both terrible I was like who
are these people never heard of what
comes up I know it's crazy that you we
could look we could look up a Mark
Norman joke in AI come on the set that
they had
um what's his name from the Patriots
dude like Tom Brady yeah have you heard
Tom Brady set no is it good it's kind of
good really
wrote it it's uh it's AI it's all AI
damn it's an AI set where Tom Brady is
like the voice and it's like a lot of
[__] jokes and it's pretty funny that
was all we had on these bees like a good
looking tall athletes and we had we were
funny and now he's got everything and
now he could have hired writers he would
have been true true regardless but at
least those writers would have gotten
worse yes good point
I know well I mean it's a crazy time
because you you you're fortunate enough
to have a job with SNL where it's you
know not a year-round job but almost
year round right yeah as opposed to
these shows like I think of all these
shows now like Barry or shows like that
they're like Eight Episodes a season
yeah and it's like the real benefit with
any writing job any like even if SNL was
like six months out of the year it's the
residuals right like that's the whole
point of the strike is like writers
could get by on one job a year because
they got residuals from that job right
and now you get a streaming job and
those jobs are a they're shorter rooms
like they last for like I don't know six
weeks or something you get no residuals
and there's less writers that they're
hiring so they're making so much more
money and yeah we're getting paid so
much less it's like a gig economy now
you can't get by wow without I mean for
me to If I Didn't Have SNL I think I'd
have to take
six like I'm saying six jobs a year
probably to like make it to make it work
like streaming jobs I started standing
my mom was like please be a screenwriter
please be a writer that's a safer job
and now I look at it like thank [__]
God yeah I did not go that route because
I was I was just thinking like the only
thing with writing to me was you have to
wait for someone to be like you're hired
right and with stand up I figured if I
could fill a room yeah I'm safe yeah
yeah that's it you got to sell tickets
yeah so what is uh what is the the suits
or whoever who are we railing against
the networks the platforms basically the
streamers okay because their stocks as
far as I understand their stocks have
plummeted last year and if they give the
writers what they want again it's going
to happen again right
um
I have not heard anything about that I I
mean I I know I've heard about Netflix's
stocks and and all that but like really
what it is is that the streamers refuse
to pay residuals and the whole strike is
about
wanting residuals from those from the
streamers because they're saying oh we
can't figure out a way to pay you
residuals because we don't we're not
broadcast right it's like well we know
that you have a way of tracking how many
views something is getting like true we
know that you we know that if you wanted
to do it you could find a way because
that's just that's like the thing in
entertainment anytime I call you know
any any rep that like can't do something
they'll be like oh yeah you know that's
not possible like not for you but it's
possible do you know what I mean every
time SiriusXM was always very shady with
their numbers as well yeah but you know
if something's hitting but it's just
funny back in the day it was such a big
thing like the box office I remember in
the paper every this is what this movie
made this is what this movie made now so
many movies come out on Netflix yeah
they're like it's top ten yeah right
right or whatever that means this is
just going to cause more independent
stuff more internet like full-on TV
shows online with real writers room yeah
and uh yeah the streamers are gonna I
think it's gonna hurt them yeah they'll
have more cakes is it cake or whatever
the [__] don't attack some great TV okay
we just we just after Mikey day we
sliced Norman in half he's a red velvet
with that jacket there have been so many
jokes about is it cake
that's a funny concept everybody shits
on is it cake and Mikey just [__]
he's such a good sport about it but it's
so fun it's everyone's favorite show to
make fun of yeah I mean I would take
that host gig I'm just saying for sure
there's gonna be a lot more British Bake
Off and all this like reality like love
is blonde yeah like was this not written
by AI yeah right that does not seem like
a human was like Love is Blind they
don't see each other that's true that
seems like a robot it feels like an
algorithm's idea yeah yeah for sure and
it's huge it's a very popular show
wasn't Bird Box a full like feature that
was kind of
yeah I think Bird Box was like I read
something about that about have you have
you made it through an episode event
these dating shows are [__] horrible
I love them women love them I watch love
I watch Love is Blind because a woman
was like watch it and I was like this is
this is bad I can't do any of it yeah
it's bad but it's so good what's the
appeal
I didn't get into it until I got
pregnant and then I was like I was home
and I was like so tired and nauseous and
it was the only thing that would like
occupy my brain whatever part of my
brain was like worried about like
whatever's going on inside of me I just
got completely outside of myself and was
able to like watch The Real Housewives
just spin out on alcohol and Adderall
Let's Escape and just fully yeah I was
like this is like watching the Super
Bowl these people yes they fight with
each other and you get to you get to
decide who won the episode after it's
your sports yeah after they've all like
thrown [__] at a dinner party yeah you
know and it never fails you're like
they're starting off happy they're
eating breakfast they're on a on a beach
and then within 17 seconds there's a
pancake going across the table yeah it's
so great when somebody starts crying at
dinner I'm like this is my [__] happy
place yeah beautiful good childhood it's
like it kind of is I mean I grew up with
four women so it's like yeah yeah my
lady she loves all that stuff but she'll
wait till I leave because I think she
wants to like get in pajamas light a
candle flick the bean in and watch the
show and so I'll come in like oh I
forgot my phone and then she's all like
you know ice cream mascara's running you
know hairs up and I'm like oh that's
your porn yeah you know because for me
it's the option I get the lotion out I
get the laptop open and then she comes
out around your neck a needle in your
arm anything about like the evanderpump
[__]
what I'm going to
just his band tonight I'm going to see
him live tonight this has all been
forced on me by a woman and it's and
it's literally just like okay it's so
good I'm like but she's like but you
hate all of them and she's like I know
I'm like so you just watch people you
hate yeah yeah but you put the Knicks on
them but they don't yeah I'm sure you
have girlfriends in the past who didn't
love you know you might not like whoever
the Knicks are playing against yeah but
the Knicks have a skill
and they're entertaining yeah yes
exactly that is a skill I mean they are
some of these women were built in a lab
for reality TV oh 100 and they're fun to
look at because a lot of them have so
much work done yeah they're like Furious
but they can't tell yeah you know like a
warning before you see their face yeah
it's crazy a member parts were like that
one's supposed to be the hot one you
have to be like yeah I totally wouldn't
[__] her that's my favorite part I would
definitely not do that well the [__] boy
island or whatever was that one the hot
Island yeah that there was some hot
ladies on that so at least it was some
eye candy well they have no filing now
and that was like literally a joke on 30
rocks yeah that's right I remember that
that was an actual show it's a and it's
a [__] great show it's a great show
it's a great show if you haven't watched
MILF Island you are I mean you're you're
just missing out like yeah what is that
one on they could be hotter if I'm being
completely honest oh yeah they could
definitely be hotter but just they're on
an island with their sons yeah it's a
great premise I came here to be
yeah you're right these people are born
for this stuff no these are 30 Rock This
is yeah today
today this is a takeoff on it I want the
real one oh excuse me yeah because those
were like the real [__]
there it's like these guys basically
these moms go to an island with theirs
you guys know the premise of the show oh
yeah tell him okay so they go to an
island with their sons and then their
sons try to [__] the other moms yeah oh
my God and that's the whole thing
I wasn't married for 14 years I want to
get a chance to do me a little young men
have much more energy oh yeah
especially in the bedroom
I'm in this amazing beautiful mansion
here what happens when they leave the
island and they go back to their shitty
life and they're still going to be with
the guy no you're about to
yeah I mean they could be dead who cares
it's just a [__] vacation I guess yeah
it's like [__] your mother [__] your
mother okay nobody gives a [__] about
their lives outside of the show the
saddest one though is
90 Day Fiance 90 Day Fiance is sad that
one bums me out too but too bummeries
that one yeah that one's a bummer yeah
Vanderpump we're laughing at how crazy
everybody is how drunk everybody is with
a guy moving from Cleveland to go to
Belarus to meet some model who's
actually in a wheelchair I mean the
whole thing is yeah the whole thing is
very sad yeah someone's always
recovering from a surgery you know they
just got or like you know what like they
just really need yeah yeah there's
always something like if you meet under
those circumstances one of you is
getting [__] yeah oh there's no way
there's no way it's just like an equal
yeah well if you I think if you meet on
any kind of reality TV
like situation you're gonna get [__]
regardless like your your life is you
have to be in a bad position I think to
go on any of these shows yes this is a
desperate plea no matter what way you
[__] cut it it's a desperate plea for
something for attention for money for uh
clout for whatever yep everybody's got
their reason for going on and all the
reasons are sad but that's why we watch
do people go on you think still thinking
I guess they their Instagrams blow up
they'd be oh yeah so you're just like
I'll be famous that's definitely yeah
you can make something like here's the
thing going on reality TV is a gamble
like you could make something out of it
right you could if you use it right you
can get successful off of it definitely
very very very few people have yes yeah
like trying to go viral right
but it was like one of the few oh yeah
Theo so is Christina P she was on there
but I was I've been to comedy clubs
where they're like oh next up is me then
Drew care then you know Mateo lane and
then Vanderpump lady oh she does stand
up yeah they'll go up and do like a q a
or something yeah yeah I've seen
stand-ups on there's like a [__] like
what was it real housewives of New York
there was like a stand-up show and I saw
a couple of stand-ups there you go yeah
but I will say 90 Day Fiance it makes me
kind of patriotic because some guys like
I'll do anything just to get to Destiny
well just to get to uh Tulsa yeah you
know and they live enough shoebox in
Tulsa and he's like oh what a country
I'm walking to Walmart looking at the
guns it's just like this is amazing yeah
it's Paradise then he got shot well he's
not the best country yeah we're working
on it right
exactly it is you're right it does make
you patriotic you realize damn America's
some people don't give up they have a
much better profession and they come
here oh yeah he's a doctor in uh Poland
and he wants to go to Tallahassee and
he'll work as a bus Tallahassee right
yeah there's that one guy that doesn't
have a neck was his name yeah he blew up
he blew up yeah he blew up yeah he's
cute he was sad enough that everybody
felt they felt for him yes yes and he's
visually stunning like what happens oh
my god there he is no neck yeah what
happened to Gene Simmons
that is crazy yeah that guy's famous
oh he's huge yeah he'll be at the cellar
I just got passed yeah he's wild who did
he marry I didn't even watch like I know
him and I never even saw this season
there's this lady she's she's pretty
cute okay she's probably like lay Ocean
or Laos I think she's Filipino Filipino
you know yeah oh yeah the hottest Asian
I say really easily that's your favorite
easy
well what do you respectfully disagree
it's either that or North Korea only
North just for the danger element it
looks like Kim Jong he's got the same
body nice screensaver by the way I
remember going on a date with a Russian
woman I was like this will never work
he's like why I was like well I can't go
to Russia with you I've made too many
Putin jokes you know right what am I
gonna meet your family that'd be the set
they're not gonna they already bailed
out grinder they're not gonna get me No
No One's Gonna rally behind me right
true although imagine having to oh Biden
or Trump like because who's a rapper
that Trump got at oh yeah
black Kodak Black not know that Russia
bailed out grinder wait what Britney oh
Griner okay I thought you said grinder
they're not cool with grinder and then I
was like thinking of the porn did you
guys see the porn documentary that
[__] pornhub.com
grinder involved in that did Russia get
okay sorry I was I had a whole [__]
no the boss
um no but I think about that the time
like imagine owing like your life to
Biden or Trump yeah yeah well who thinks
they got the shoot what was that guy the
killer who was the guy we traded for
Griner oh the uh [__] what's this he's
like a crazy The Merchant of death
that's it Merchant of death
Good Times damn not a good trade not
great yeah you didn't really see that in
the news very much you just saw griner's
back he didn't he he didn't see we
traded Griner for The Merchant of death
yeah Victor about so he killed a bunch
of people and we arrested him I think he
was an arms dealer like a huge arms
dealer yeah they're both taking shots
yeah
do we have any news stories
here we go all right
um
yeah this one's fun all right welcome
back to the writer's room you thought
you had a break I was like Jesus Christ
you'll be in Mexico before you know it
uh an Australian artist is bringing the
experience of death to life via the
participatory participatory virtual
reality simulator showing people what it
could be like
as if you're dying you know loves this
dying people they're in jail like what
or not jail in the hospital laying in a
bed like what the [__] it's like DMT for
cowards
I heard this uh someone's experimenting
with a DMT drip
really so it's not just like a a
30-second thing it's like an hour-long
prolonged DMT trip can you choose how
you're dying is this very vague are we
talking about falling off the cliff you
can do like uh Boulevard attack and they
revive you oh yeah so it's like they say
it's very realistic also I heard he came
up with one where uh it's as if you're
getting raped in prison oh nice and uh
yeah it's very realistic you watch they
walk in they say are you with the Aryan
Nation you say it only goes downhill
from there babe
I know it I think it's very realistic
you could do like I look it up it's like
heart attack really it can do uh but
what is that you just what do you see it
vibrates okay okay and then uh I don't
know what else it was like what else did
they have imagine getting the wrong
vibrator in the bedroom your wife's like
hey get that vibe there you're actually
gonna get a bunch of people doing DMT at
his [__] exhibit yes true this is
what's gonna happen oh my God High dying
High yeah they're gonna you're gonna
have some [__] up people going to
these
I don't think I'll choose the VR episode
where I get [__] to death by the horse
yeah you remember that video
that's what I want to get
that's what the goggles on
by the way they don't know this isn't
realistic you don't know how you're
gonna die you get hit by a bus tomorrow
yeah this is like dying as if you die
slowly in a hospital yeah this isn't
like like you could get stabbed by your
wife tomorrow yeah third world countries
aren't talking to you Syracuse yeah
I mean I guess I would pick just uh
killing myself over yeah I'd rather just
kill myself this is this would be great
if Mark took it and it was just me
driving this car
that I saw yeah a man who advocated
caning for adultery gets caned for it
I'm loving an eye for an eye nice this
is like when the chancellor gets
canceled it's fun when the the [__]
happens yeah reverse uh an Indonesian
man has been publicly flogged for
adultery under the Draconian law which
he helped create oh Indonesian hottest
Asian
they this is like Scarlet Letter [__]
yeah yeah I mean you have a mark on your
back they can you I'm surprised this has
happened to a man
oh they hit the woman too it comes up
next oh they hit her too yeah yeah for
adultery 28 lashes interesting now what
is the adultery because that's also very
vague I guess uh sex outside of marriage
when you're married she got it too okay
the wife no I'm kidding might as well
literally that's what where my brain
went yeah I was like it's they're
probably hitting the wife but that's
kind of nice that you at least now it's
like a Level Playing Field like if she
sticks around and she's like you cheated
on me at least now he's like yo my
[__] back is [__] up yeah I have a
hole in my heart why have a [__]
permanent scar right okay yeah I feel
like it's fair true yeah you get
punished yeah I like the idea that if
you cheat it's like hey it's our secret
don't say anything you need to get cane
don't tell my wife oh good call oh it
actually encourages yeah secrecy guy
you're thinking about cheating on his
wife right yeah yeah yeah now you're
thinking like a married guy also what if
you're into pain we were talking about
the ball stomping earlier this uh Wall
Street guys like their balls stop what
if you like a little caning maybe that's
like where he got the idea yeah
he just comes all over that [__]
that's gonna suck for that executioner
type guy whatever yeah because he's one
of those dudes in a mask who just like
beats you I guess what a weird gig I
know how do you get that game I'd like
to apply for the caner please you got
some anger problems I think right by the
way it says also they can you if you're
drunk in public I think what or gay so
Mark you wouldn't last a [__] minute
over there for which reason
Marcus walks in I'm gay I get him look
at that guy I'm drunk and I'm gay yeah
well they lead to each other too
thinking if you're a gay dude who cheats
on your wife oh you're double cane yeah
right damn I'm Michael Caine
[Laughter]
um here's an interesting story some
studios I'm looking into having AI
generators grips during the ride which
Studios some
they do good work some uh that are
punched up by human counterparts once
the strike has been settled
yeah I already I mean I clearly did my
research on the way over here and uh I
was like that's fine with me
do you see the meme that said AI is
taking 300 million jobs it's just a
picture of Allen Iverson yeah well
that's a pretty good meme yeah I don't
get it like
I'm an idiot yeah yeah
sorry
[Laughter]
like do you think this is gonna [__]
right in
I don't know I mean I I just kind of
like dude after the last four years I'm
kind of like I get if it happens you
know it happens it's like we've lived
through [__] the craziest
the craziest time I think to live
through in comedy oh 100 and I'm like
right if this were to happen I'd be like
all right yeah why not why wouldn't it
yeah and if it's one of those things you
can't stop it like we go TVs are crazy
kids aren't reading anymore they're
staying all day TVs are here to stay
cars they're gonna kill the horse and
buggy Community that's gone you know
it's just things I know phones you know
you can't stop technology what I will
say is this I don't I feel okay I mean
you know famous last words like I feel
okay
with people
that have job like kind of people in our
class on our you know what I mean in our
where we're at yeah but I do feel really
horribly for people that are just now
starting out oh 100 like I I just feel
like oh my god what the [__] are they
what would they do but some of them are
gonna laugh other comedians because of
the technology true true there's also
that yeah they could and a lot of them
probably are going to be great and then
some of them are going to suck I mean
it's like you see some of these Comics
blowing up on Tick Tock too soon and
they get to the clubs and they don't
have a really
headlining because they have a following
you know right yeah a lot of that but I
was in a green room on the road recently
with some young whippersnapper who's
hosting for me and I was like well you
guys I can't correct the code on this
bit and he goes have you thought about
this and they were all great suggestions
like man this kid's good but he pulled
up AI but I'd even think to do this the
chat gbt because I was just working on a
bid and he gave me like eight good tags
and I was like those are all
he wouldn't know he was just yeah I was
doing it on his phone and I was like oh
my God so he could just come up with a
premise and then do this [__] and then
he's like oh I got 12 punch lines I'll
try to it's a great idea then you just
look at him and you shoot him in the
face yeah
I was nervous I was like oh no that's
[__] crazy crazy crazy and now I'm
using one of the tags
gotta give that robot a special thanks I
guess so you're not special no I'm like
before AI I think Mark was the closest
thing we had
a robot who tells jokes that's my thing
it's scary it is scary it's [__] it's
terrifying we're always looking at to
save money it just sucks when it happens
and creative spaces because this is like
where you thought you were saying I
thought we were safe yeah no yeah but
you're gonna have to have a big Persona
now people are gonna like fluffy fluffy
I don't always act that well but he's so
lovable and the crowds love him he sells
out everywhere Arenas yeah I think if he
had a high comedy people would just be
like well we want want to see fluffy
right so you need to have a thing now
it's crazy that you know like truckers
and people are like oh now you [__]
care right you know what I mean like all
these people that were losing jobs for
this yeah true true you know yeah but AI
can't do offensive humor can it
can you pull up the the I keep I keep
thinking Ted Bundy and I know that's not
his name thank you
can you look up the top Tom Brady uh AI
stand up set okay I just want you guys
to hear some of it all right is it dirty
it's dirty I mean it's like damn it it's
not like sexual dirty but it's got
there's so many [__] jokes yeah he uses
closer now to lunch too
all right
all right slow down the momentum of
everything also they gotta pay for your
likeness so maybe you'll just get if
they do a Sam Morel stay I thing they'll
still have to pay you for using your I
think so for using your face and
everything I don't think they have to do
that oh [__] I mean I don't know how you
would that's kind of what the
in a way that's like what the writers
strike we're trying to like negotiate
with them about Ai and about the
advancements that are happening and they
like the responses have been just like
will check in about advancements in
technology once a year yeah you can just
talk about it which it's like what
that's terrifying should we just get
together and be like pretty impressive
what happened this year yeah it feels
like it's gonna end up like squid games
yeah yeah one writer gets paid everyone
competes against each other they murder
all the rest yeah oh no
yeah it's scary but I do think I think
what's going to happen is we got the
rider strike the DGA is going to get
involved I think sag is going to get
involved and then they're going to have
every single person every ever iatse is
getting involved too and I think once
they all all the other unions kind of
join into the strike then they're gonna
be kind of like [__] because if they
don't have crew right right then they
can't shoot anything if they don't have
a director they can't shoot anything
true true so that [__] with reality
yeah too that's true okay that gives me
hope does this look like it's it I knew
we had it too good for too long I
thought I'd be bad at this but honestly
it's pretty easy not as easy as winning
a Super Bowl but pretty easy you know
when I decided I was going to do
stand-up I asked some other big Comics
what kind of Comedy they thought I
should start with and I got some great
advice across the board they said stay
away from talking about football talk
about anything else in your life but if
you're serious about comedy you can't
rely on who you were as a football
player
yeah right this gives me hope this is
this is not funny how many people here
tonight have been in a huddle okay put
your hand down if your last huddle was
in Pop Warner okay put your hand down if
your last huddle was in high school
college the XFL
not stand up I guess I guess they played
the part of it that is it like that was
the that was but it was
it I I guess it took a long time to get
into it but then he started talking
about like taking a [__] and everyone we
were all listening to it we were like
because we were all like oh whatever
this is nothing this isn't scary and
then he started talking about he started
telling [__] jokes and we were all like
yeah that's scary [__] jokes and fart
jokes that's everybody loves dogs yeah
yeah those are a hit good point
knocked it off maybe just put in uh Tom
Brady [__] jokes AI you got it yeah give
that a shot
but um anyway I didn't mean to no no
this is interesting yeah it's kind of
like I can't stop thinking YouTube I
can't either and here's my theory I
think it's gonna be two camps it's gonna
be like acoustic and auto-tune like we
want to just see a band play or we want
to see a DJ right you know and I think
it'll be like that with AI comedy like
no we want to go see Rosebud live
or we'll go see this AI thing for half
the price I think it's gonna turn into
like a human versus computer thing yeah
yeah we want to see Mark Norman live at
the Funny Bone no like no [__] that I
want to see the Tom Brady remix yeah
yeah exactly exactly
I I do feel like
even the internet sorry even the
internet is kind of like [__] with
just the way that I do my set on the
road you know what I mean where it's
like I I end and then I have to do like
15 minutes of just like back and forth
with the audience to find something to
cut up you know what I mean so it's like
that alone is kind of depressing and
then and then not that I mind
interacting with the audience like that
but there's it just gets to be like
kind of Soul crushing a night where I'm
like I don't really give a [__] about I
just wanted to do my set right right and
it's a huge epidemic in comedy Now with
like the the clip chasing yeah what was
that I've seen it yeah and sometimes
you're following someone doing that at
the cellar or something you're like dude
you're [__] just chasing I'm a seller
yeah I've seen it it's like 15 minutes
exactly I'll do it on the road and I
even at the I used to do at the end of
my set I try to sneak it in for maybe
like two minutes and I try to not do it
too much anymore because I don't wanna I
don't want the influence the way I do
comedy I feel like if you're at the
cellar doing that
you're at a level where you should be
doing a every time I agree yeah and it
should be a comedy club like what do
your ideas what are your thoughts I
don't like the idea of like where are
you guys from nothing there okay what
about you nothing there like this you're
entertaining you're not asking questions
I get a little crowd work I get that no
I always put the whole thing I'll
sneaking in an hour but I I did that
before this [__] because I did it
because if you don't do it the Rhythm
becomes predictable so you do it you do
it for the sake of the material as well
still for the material yeah yeah well do
you have more I got better looking or
not but I can tell you one thing I can't
do anymore suck my own dick yeah you
heard me right I know you know people
can do this I know you've seen it on the
internet interesting well I used to be
one of those people then somewhere about
two or three years ago I just couldn't
do it anymore don't know if my dick
shrank or my spine just lost flexibility
but let me tell you something if you are
a person who can still suck your own
dick cherish it never have a worse
moment than when you're naked ass in the
air folded up on top of yourself just
staring at your own dick dangling a
quarter inch from your lips
if you saw a comic doing that in a club
you wouldn't be like wow that's clever
you'd be like no it's fine no I wouldn't
be okay he's got a squeaky clean you
know good image but that doesn't mean
but not everything that's clever is
funny you know what I mean right
sometimes it's just stupid and it makes
me laugh yeah because it's a guy trying
to suck his own dick yeah I think if I
saw a comic do that in a club I'd be
like the fact that it's coming out of
his mouth is funny yeah it's scary that
that's at least AI is is making
something at least that funny yeah at
least hack level is [__] that's
impressive that's impressive I can't
wait to see Peyton Manning's material
about eating ass
I hate to ask for like Jesus
[Music]
speaking of I have a another news story
for you a Tennessee Hotel night manager
charged after a guest woke up to him
sucking on his toes nice that's just
part of the hotel service yeah I think
it's that's what we call a wake-up call
on certain hotel
better than the Doubletree I'm sick of
that cookie suck my toes
yeah you call you call for a wake-up
call at a Red Roof Inn that's what
you're getting somebody's gonna suck
your toes it is you know it's uh he went
on he he disappeared to I think Lebanon
because I read this and he really and
this happened in Tennessee that's like
the saddest reason to go in the lamb
ever you're just hiding because you suck
toes in another country right like
arrested Neil and Lebanon in his home
Friday according to detectives so if the
hotel chain gets more expensive does he
suck better things
he's doing the toes if I get Four
Seasons
you walk into the Ritz I expect the best
right 700 a night
wow that is wild suck and toes so his
his need to suck a toe was so strong
that he was doing it on random clients
and he went in with a key card that's
why you got to put that bolt up yeah but
the bolt up but that's also like what a
weird fetish like under first I don't
even understand really like a foot
fetish on women it's just not my thing
same but uh but on men men's feet are
disgusting yeah it's a hoof yeah my
nails are yellow they're crooked it's
not good it's gross I look like a catch
salmon with my [__] crazy bunion oh
corn what is Kevin ISO has a great joke
about he saw a woman with like the
second toe was longer than the big toe
and he said it looked like his her foot
was offering him a cigarette
wow that's hilarious that's great suck
on that Tom Brady yeah
so funny I should work at athlete's foot
damn toe suck
um you're a lady dude you appreciate a
toe suck no I don't want anyone near my
feet yeah for for their sake really
right you know what I mean how about
fresh out of the shower I still don't
think so no I don't I'm not you know
what I mean it's like if I was it feels
like for me to be into that I would have
to have the feet that I had when I was
like five and I just I don't wanna the
whole difference you don't want that guy
yeah I don't want that guy either
we might be drunk is brought to you by
uh display thank you for sponsoring
today's episode display makes high
quality metal posters that can be
installed on your walls in seconds they
make for really unique gifts so you
don't have to just if you're if you're
struggling I don't know what to get your
buddy's getting married get him some
sick art for the man cave you can
literally print anything on a disc plate
and make your own custom piece or they
have you know officially licensed
designed uh Harry Potter Call of Duty uh
a ton I think they got back to school on
there uh that's probably what I would go
with what you what you go to uh I would
go old movies give me a give me a nice
taxi driver or uh maybe a uh you know
Cuckoo's Nest they got everything over
there Elvira some little titties on the
wall another one with that click the
link in our description to see some of
our favorites and get ready to hang your
piece of art save 20 off 27 off rather
if you buy one or two or 34 four percent
off when you buy three or more the
discount will automatically be applied
to your cart when you click our link use
code drunk when you visit display.com to
get the discount that's display.com code
drunk or click the show notes uh the
link in the notes hey hey folks we might
be drunk as brought to you by fit bye
it's almost summertime when you're
trying to get in shape you need to check
out fitbot it's an app that creates a
workout program customized to your goals
Fitness level and available equipment it
even learns from your previous workouts
and adapts your personalized plan as you
improve
I love fitbod I love home workout [__]
going to the gym and being put out by
these queefs over there they bench press
you out the yin yang they think they're
better than you they look at you funny
they grunt it's cheaper than a personal
trainer and a great way to ease into
your Fitness style if you're not quite
ready for a workout public that's me
whether you're a local beginner a total
beginner or an expert looking for
something new to add to your routine
fitbot has got you covered there's no
better time to level up your Fitness
habit try fitbod today it's about to be
summer folks you got to get in shape get
25 off your subscription or try the app
for free at
fitbod.me drunk that's
fitbod.me drunk fitbod.me drunk get on
it
hey folks we might be drunk as brought
to you by rocket money
most Americans think they spend 80 a
month on subscription the real total is
closer to two hundo if you don't know
how much money you're spending on
subscriptions and you need rocket money
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place quickly and easily view all of
your subscriptions and cancel any you
don't want the touch of a button I love
rocket money I had all kinds of audible
and Spotify and Amazon and Hulu and all
this [__] was [__] me right in the
ass
now I know and now I'm out thanks to
Rocket money even put your expenses into
categories and alert you if anything
looks off it's budgeting in one easy
move those little five dollar charges
can add up baby download rocket money
today and take control of your finances
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com
drunk that's rocketmoney.com drunk
flash drunk thank you
yeah no it's a weird I'm not trying to
shame anybody here I just it's the
fetish that never spoke to me you know
but I know it's a huge fetish I mean
that's feet are huge yeah keeping only
fans alive I think they'd like studied
there's something in like
I I heard something I never read it but
I heard something about how like guys
who are in defeat it's like a certain
part of their brain like they did MRIs
oh I believe it and because they are
like into it in a way that they're more
open about it than other fetishes
totally totally how do you handle the
summer
yeah just feed everywhere I was thinking
the same thing how do you handle it it's
it's a it's a gift if you have a foot
fetish you don't want to be out getting
boners in public
but if I saw a bunch of tits out I
wouldn't be like this is a curse you
know I mean this is great yeah but you
would have to go home sometimes that's
true that's true luckily you live in the
village you could just run back inside
yes yes exactly and you go back out
you're like I [__] hate myself
The Village you could run between cars
really yeah true the right day I'll just
run between two homeless guy also
jerking off
he's gonna get killed and he'll be six
feet under all right
all right we got a New Zealand man
legally changed his name to the longest
possible name which is Captain Fantastic
faster than Superman Spider-Man Batman
Wolverine Hulk and the Flash combined
name change was done uh to protest a
strict name laws in New Zealand this guy
can never [__] about pronouns
oh I gotta call you she her [__] you my
name is Superman Batman Spiderman
Wolverine also this guy's clearly a
virgin I'd say or premature ejaculated
or that faster than Superman yeah yeah
how about how about when a guy out does
him like when a guy's a more shocking
name if a guy's like oh you're you're
faster than a speeding bullet I'm a
glory hole Jackson
I'm really confused about these strict
name laws though what what even I don't
get why it to some degree though I mean
you can fit that on a license what are
you doing yeah true I get [__] sometimes
I'll fly an airline and for whatever
reason every time I fly United it's uh
my name is Sam e Morel but it always
comes out in the ticket same Morel it's
always an issue when I go through
security I can't change it yeah but it
feels like the law was created for this
specific guy not this guy protesting a
lot do you know what I mean right a guy
like this yeah I'm like how many guys
are doing this in New Zealand where this
is like a problem right they they put it
in place to uh let's see
for offensive names and names over 99
characters oh is he known he's under 99
yeah for offensive names yeah okay how
about how about David tells bit about
what he would name his kid uh Pizza
[__] Santa because everyone likes one
of those things
Pizza [__] Santa it's a classic great
combination of things he's so [__]
funny Santa's really good yeah yeah it's
a clincher right there right right he
thought he's gonna go three p's
Pizza
these games did pass the ban which was
midnight Chardonnay and twins named
Benson and hedges okay Midnight
Chardonnay is a dope name
that's a [__] awesome name it's like
an R B singer I love it yeah or a black
detective novel yeah that's our the
world's next star yeah her mother's name
was afternoon Chardonnay
thanks
dad or her dad was a morning wood
dumbest episodes yeah right for sure
[Music]
[Laughter]
well the Secret's out guys this podcast
had writers
so who's hers or or again he's the
president Turkish
okay I thought he was my uh
I love that at the end of the day he's
kind of he's pulling the old American
thing being like well that guy's gay
yeah exactly Turkish opposition is gay
yeah that's great yeah that's funny so
ahead of the crucial election this month
the incumbent president argued that uh
only his party can protect family values
and that his opposition is gay
I do this to women if they won't sleep
with me I'm like you hate juice
it's a good tactic I tried the same
tactic uh running for president of high
school come on Jeff's gay
it is like my mom will do this to me too
where she'll like she knows I don't like
the word hack so if I'm hungover someone
should be like oh that's so hack oh
yeah that's great I made breakfast I
don't like uh scrambled eggs come on
yeah that's great
that works for everything yeah it really
does you're a hack yeah if any of my
sisters or family started using that
word I think I'd I'd lose my mind yeah
use my [__] mind on them yeah because
it hurts it stays yeah they're using it
against me and they don't even know what
it [__] means you know that's like
that's brutal you called CPS uh my mom
keeps calling me a hack
that's not really but some of my sisters
would definitely do them I call it AI
for a comeback how do I get my mom back
for this [__] you know you get her back
call her a MILF that'll scare the [__]
out of her
coming from a sun
she's Googling it oh no MILF Island
Trump is like one step away from using
this tactic I think what's this just
calling everyone gay yeah oh yeah he has
hasn't done that no he said the f word I
think he went all in he's
definitely called somebody the r word oh
yeah meatball Ron is a great nickname
it's so much funnier than calling
someone chubby yeah meatballs meatball
is funny yeah Crooked Hill you're fat is
lame but shut up meatball Ron that's
funny where's he testing these out like
is he like in a room with God I don't
think he I think he's like I think he's
like a genius he's got a gift stand up
he's like sleepy Joe drill he has like a
gift and it's just bullying you know
well he tries to get sanctimonious on
stage and it got nothing and then he
caught a meatball run I got a laugh he
does it the way we do it yeah yeah he
workshops me yeah yeah he's like which
is a tough you know draw it's like yeah
you have to understand sanctimonious
meatball everyone gets and it's a
mouthful sanctimonious it's too much
it's more clever but it's not right what
do you need yeah it's not what I need
I have one more here a woman in Japan
married a character from the video game
love plus the wedding ceremony was held
in a Tokyo Hall and the bride wore a
white wedding dress while her groom was
displayed on screen
woman stated that she fell in love with
the character's personality and couldn't
imagine being with a real person now
this is either
either an old story or this has happened
before because I've seen this really
yeah I've I've seen I've seen a video of
a woman getting I saw a video of the of
the wedding and she was she was dead
seriously she she fell in love with like
the city it was like the Sims or
something yeah what is this game I've
never heard it's like the Sims
Plus sounds like my ex he's a big lady
that sounds like a shopping center like
a shopping brand for plus size women
it's also like a thing where it's like
that's great if you want to marry a fake
thing but like do I have to get you a
gift
we have to celebrate do we have to do I
have to cancel plans to be at your
wedding yeah I feel like I feel like
there was nobody at the wedding when I
saw the oh really that makes sense there
was nobody there they were all just like
oh [__] oh yeah this is from 2009. oh
good call what are you doing with these
old stories
[Laughter]
yeah this is the his next story is uh
Lincoln freed the slaves this is crazy
this is wild oh Jake Paul stuff that
like you wouldn't
really know or hear about unless you
were just bored in a writer's room
anyway you know what I mean this is all
[__] that I've learned on a Thursday
during rewrites right I'm just Googling
references from sketches that I don't
understand yeah I like the the nerdy
guys mom's like when are you gonna meet
somebody he's like I just can't find
Pokemon
I can't find her all right get to the
Lorena Bobbitt story yeah I know right
Tom Brady's got an AI bit about it
all right we did the news the news
yeah plenty out there so are you hitting
the road before Mexico I'm not I'm going
so Mexico Italy then I do the road then
I'm then I'm starting my tour June uh
July and August what if they go hey the
strike's off and you're knee-deep and
pasta well we're on no no we're oh no no
we wouldn't be because we'd had we had
three weeks left so there's a chance
let's say the strike ends which it won't
and Lauren is like we're starting this
week I'd have to come back from Mexico
but I don't think that's gonna happen
yeah you're praying to keep that strike
going I really don't think that's gonna
happen what makes you think the strike
is going to be prolonged like that
because the last one was like a hundred
days and The List of Demands was so much
shorter and the stakes were so much
lower oh really yeah and they got
everything they wanted yeah wow yeah I
mean I'm not saying I don't think we'll
get everything we want on this one but I
don't think they'll
settle for I mean because the stakes are
so high for Fighters I don't think
they'll settle it doesn't sound like I
don't know anything about it you know
but it doesn't sound like Netflix is
budging no oh no they're not no one's
budging but SNL gets residuals but you
guys are just
solidarity yeah got it exactly is it
because yes because you're not on
streaming I guess you're on peacock and
but you're also on mbbc right yeah okay
but yeah it's like you don't know I mean
it's every writing job is temporary true
true you don't want to be out of life's
a timeshare too man yeah Society but
have we got some scabs yet has anyone
cross the line I don't think so out of
them let's out them I did go into the
building to get a couple things out of
my uh office which I think you're not
supposed to do oh really what do you get
like my plants
I was just like sneaking in you're gonna
be a good mom you've got the plans yeah
which is weed
this is I mean do you feel okay being
pregnant is that yeah yeah I feel fine I
mean the first trimester
I'm like working it's not the most
feminist thing I've ever said but
working during the first trimester
should be [__] illegal I was like
this is [__] brutal this is so hard
and some women don't it doesn't like
[__] with them the way that it did for
me but I was I was like I just felt like
I was gonna throw up the whole time and
I never did and I was like waiting for
like the moment when I could finally
throw up all day well that's basically
what it felt like damn and then and then
you're so [__] tired that you feel
like you've taken a sleeping pill and
you're just trying to like get through
your day having accidentally taken a
sleeping pill damn and you're not
supposed to have coffee and you're not
supposed to smoke and so like I had to
stop smoking I had to stop drinking
coffee which eventually I just went [__]
it I'm gonna drink coffee like I have to
yeah
um and then uh and now I'm like feeling
a hundred times better like it's just
like one day you wake up and your
Energy's back and you're like oh okay
cool yeah but then I guess it gets hard
again at the third trimester so wow so
if you're thinking about just one yes
okay so you can't do coffee when you're
pregnant well you're not supposed to but
I have been I mean if it's 11 o'clock at
night and I have two shows and I need a
Red Bull I'm gonna have a red ball like
you know all basically all I feel is
like her kicking me more like it's she
just kind of like goes a little nuts you
just hear her scream yeah she's like it
wasn't good
fighting a raccoon in my stomach yeah
but it's like it is a weird feeling
because now I'm kind of at the I'm at
the exciting part she's like starting to
move and start I can feel her in there
and she's like oh it's so weird when you
feel them start to like swim around it
it does not feel like normal yeah it
feels like you have like eels swimming
around in your stomach it's a [__]
alien feeling it's weird I mean if I was
pregnant because if I have to take a
huge [__] I get nervous so I can't
imagine yeah the vagina fear you're
having dude I'd be terrified nine months
of just anxiety about the stretching on
the podcast with two dudes I had Taco
Bell one time it was crazy it kind of is
like that though from what I've heard
like it from what I've heard it's it is
like the scariest moment of course is am
I gonna rip everything yes yes my mom
ripped I don't know if he wants me
saying but she ripped the butthole to
vagina taint Jesus the taint ripped gone
yeah yeah I signed it later I was like
that was my work that is so hack
I have been reading like horror stories
on Reddit oh don't do that I don't know
why I keep doing this it's like I know
you're supposed to like focus on like
meditating or whatever and like
practicing your breathing but instead of
doing that I'm just like looking on
Reddit at like trauma birth stories oh
my God and women being like I guess
because I'm like then I'm prepared for
the worst sure in my mind I'm like well
it's better than what happened to that
one lady right right do you know what I
mean I got a great man for you uh
Rosemary's Baby
I love that movie that's a good movie
yeah in the Dakota yeah all right wow
and you got a name uh I do have a name I
think I'm just we're we're not like
telling anybody okay because it feels
like it'll ruin it yeah you know well
you've already done this don't tell
anyone ever really don't tell anyone
ever because even when the baby's born
just don't tell anyone yeah yeah just
yeah everyone's just baby and then
they'll turn you off that name a little
bit Yeah [__] up so just yeah keep it
yourself he wanted to name his baby
Captain Fantastic
right yeah people laughed at him and he
got cold feet
I do I'm kind of like it is kind of
scary because the name that we picked is
like a little a little unique where I'm
just kind of like I don't want I don't
want it to sound like I'm trying to it's
it's a nickname that my aunt had and so
I I'm not trying to like
you know I I don't know steal it no I
just don't want people thinking that
it's some are you trying too hard yes ah
yeah you don't have like a Gwyneth
Paltrow Apple Lighthouse yeah yeah I
don't want it to sound like that um well
we'll pull up chat gbt
exactly but I'm psyched I'm really all
right are you guys thinking about having
kids or no I think in about a year I'll
do it yeah yeah the lady's pretty pumped
and it's all she talks about and
whenever we see a kid she has to go nuts
and play with it and all that so yeah
and I'd like uh yeah you don't want to
do I'm a little far from that right sure
sure it's really just one mistake away
that's true you drink it
could happen if ladies if you're
watching I drink
heard that
[Laughter]
I know because of me six months from now
[__] [__]
just don't have it on the road in Texas
it wasn't it wasn't crazy that when I
tell you guys this
so I don't think he would mind me
telling you but he so he had this idea
and he I call him up and I was like you
got to come home I got to tell you
something and so and I know that's a
[__] up way to tell somebody news but
like if he thinks I'm mad at him he's
not gonna ask me follow-up questions do
you know what I mean so I was like true
it'll take longer for him to come home
but he's not going to ask me any
questions that'll make me like spill the
beans good point right so he comes home
I I tell him the news and he goes um all
right well I gotta tell you something
then uh oh and I was like
[__] I was like what is it and he goes
um I thought like maybe somebody else
was pregnant you know what I mean I was
like what did you do he goes
uh I've been thinking about going to the
Ukraine
he's like I bought a ticket to the
Ukraine to fight that's what I said yeah
he goes no I was gonna film a video
and I was I was I wasn't going to tell
you I was going and then I was going to
get there and I was going to FaceTime
you and film it and I just thought it'd
be funny to see how mad you got this is
how bad we need content this is out of
control exactly I I literally was like
I kind of wish you had cheated
I wish you had just hooked somebody else
this is so much worse yeah now I'm like
now I'm just carrying around your dumb
[__] DNA
how about you write a new bit Andy
yeah just write a new joke God damn it
Jesus Christ you give birth in the
Ukraine just give him a middle finger
but I was like as far as Ukraine content
goes that is pretty fun it's pretty
funny yeah but it's a flight it's a it's
a whole thing just for one 12 second
video yeah yeah he loves to do that he's
the king of like more effort less payoff
he's Andy loves that [__] they are funny
jokes yeah yeah yeah that's yeah that's
not it's a weird uh response to I'm
pregnant yeah I was like how did I tell
you I'm pregnant and you just like stole
the show
what the [__] he Putin you I know this
is crazy damn well he's not gonna go
right no all right are you kidding me we
got a kid to raise here yeah I was like
well you're not going that's not
happening yeah
um come on so [__] that that'd be the
worst way to die I know you go to
Ukraine it's a joke and then you're like
now I'm a single mom are you [__]
kidding me no I know I was like let's
say you actually died and then I gotta
find out that you were a in the Ukraine
B trying to go viral
I know right I'm like what the [__] do I
tell our kid Jesus your dad was really
stupid he died you just tell the Kitty
dead you died in Ukraine and the kid's
like my daddy fought in the War yeah
like no he was an idiot
he's an influencer
Jesus I know you've had fun he died in
the Ukraine war was he was he Ukrainian
no no no no no no no he was on Tick Tock
he was in content Wars
happy duck with the TNT blows himself up
just for the one joke right yeah yeah
that's it I was like God damn it
well I don't know am I allowed to say
what you got it in vitro oh no actually
oh really that's the crazy part is like
we did IVF we got like six embryos
they're chilling in the probably close
to here like what yeah and uh and we got
pregnant by accident get out of here
yeah I had covid that month I thought
like there's no chance I was like
there's no chance this is gonna last I
mean this is a depressing thing to say
but I was like well this will just be a
bad three weeks at work yeah yeah and
then I'll [__] and then we'll take
care of it right but I but then like 12
weeks went by and I was like oh I'm
still I'm still pregnant and I know like
what I'm having and like yeah and I was
like it took me a long time to tell
people because I just thought that's
crazy you know yeah well can we get the
uh IVF money back yeah no [__] I'm like
how do we that's pretty expensive do I
sell those embryos I think you sell them
yeah some of this guy because he's he
shoots blanks
yeah do you just have a little blonde
kid yeah just a little blonde blue-eyed
this is my this is my son Apple
yeah we didn't have any boys though well
we had one but they were like you don't
want that one
that would be a stand-up comedian
this one this one's like Andy
do you think's going to the Ukraine this
morning
he's just farting and everybody was just
farting like it's not comedy he's like
hack attack
[__] so I think that's kind of cute
though that your mom does I think that's
great pretty funny yeah it's pretty cute
she's not doing it to be funny she
thinks it's like getting to me I know
but that's why it's cute yeah I ordered
like a third beer at dinner and she's
like that is hack you gotta stop with
this that was what my grandfather was
too he was like it was like a different
generation he just didn't they didn't
drink like we do so or at least my
family they drink more well maybe like
the Don Draper type people yeah not
everybody I mean yeah uh I mean they
also thought a glass of milk was healthy
probably true and smoking yeah but uh
the milk was like our generation oh yes
does a body good yeah that was big but I
feel like a lot of milk propaganda I
remember my grandfather I'd ordered like
a second beer and he'd be like he had
two beers all right yeah I'd be like
freaking out two beers yeah Jesus Christ
like Catholic
nuts my parents do the the guilt uh the
coming late Gill so what time did you
get in and I'm like I don't know maybe 1
30 like sounded more like 3 30. they're
eating breakfast I'm like [__] well
don't ask yeah that's [__] up I'm an
adult I know that's like the one thing
that getting sober that is the one perk
where I'm like my mom never really
worries about my life choices having
gotten sober you would have sober baby
yeah that's crazy yeah what do you mean
both of you are sober yeah oh I'm making
a certified alcoholic for sure oh yeah
but we uh we were sober we made her
at least because my lady is a booze bag
so she's worried about the the pregnancy
sober thing but you had a smooth
transish yeah that part was but the
vaping was I mean I truly the second I
give birth I'm gonna rip an elf bar so
hard No One's Gonna tell what gender the
kid is the whole [__] hospital room
is gonna be full of a vape Cloud do you
smoke is it weed or just like nicotine
no just nicotine what kind of what's
your flavors it's anything that like
they would sell to a 13 year old like
strawberry daiquiri or like banana
sundae I'm just I'll go for it you
should hit it in the in the room while
your legs are still in stirrups and
maybe it'll come out come right out yeah
she's like in here
yeah I should I can't wait I feel great
when you're drunk I I do craves like I I
think they're gross sober but if I have
a few drinks to me and if someone has a
vape pen I'm like [__] let me try
it's weird every pregnant woman I've
talked to was like yeah I just smoking
became disgusting to me coffee became
disgusting I'm like I haven't wanted to
drink in like 13 years I want to drink
again it's a weird something is wrong
with me like my pregnancy cravings are
all for [__] that I don't that I
shouldn't there's no pressure but you
would be our first pregnant alcoholic on
the show today that would be big big
ratings baby yeah
damn sorry to let you guys down what
about I could pregnant porn
how do you feel about that pregnant porn
well it's so popular that you could
clean up on only fans just by showing
the belly yeah I could do that
it's an idea good I mean listen the
strike goes on long enough I got a lot
to work with here oh yeah because the
the horn go up the horny because I've
heard that yeah I mean it is Andy
it does for some wait either goes up or
it goes down and for me it's definitely
gone down oh and for me I don't like
we're we're still having sex but it's a
process for me where it's like I feel
like I'm doing physical therapy I'm
trying and I'm I it which is not what
any man wants to hear no but there's
literally like the first time we did it
I just said I was like you're all over
the place get out
that's what the baby said too which was
like
it's not as
people inside me
it felt so weird oh that's wild it just
felt too weird to me I was like oh I
can't do this I should pick the baby
going
no one don't come in the door's locked
his dick in the baby
Jesus Christ I don't want to say to me
recently uh she was tired and she's like
if you have I'm really tired but if you
have sex with me while I'm sleeping I
won't call it rape and I'm just like
yeah that's what you want to hear
that's an insane thing I'm rock hard now
thanks
that is a crazy thing to say to somebody
yeah
what should have sucked her toes in her
sleep
she'd call that room Fleet of Lebanon
you'll never catch me I don't think
it'll be that weird for me when my
lady's pregnant we already [__] like
she's pregnant we got the roll over
we're very lazy sex TV's on behind her
yeah on the side you know perfect so
yeah you got it set oh we're all set
we're credits roll written by AI yeah
yeah
anal insertion
that's great you got any dates you want
to plug coming up oh yeah over the
emergency room in a couple of months
yeah seriously I mean I'm doing um
Springfield uh that's a good room oh
thank you my website is helpful if you
just scroll down that'll be yeah so uh
Blue Room what is that June 9th 8th
through 10th uh I'm gonna be on fully
loaded oh it's nice yeah Zanies uh in
tennis that's a great room
Chicago
oh uh what is that Huntsville Alabama
yeah that's fully loaded July 6th doing
a couple uh fully loaded those are fun
those are gonna be really fun Milwaukee
improv uh
improv nothing City Casino which don't
even I mean that'll be yeah it's a
paycheck it's a paycheck for sure
um Tampa Improv yeah all my web all my
shows are on my website rosebudbaker.com
comedy crowds Tampa oh yeah does it say
Tampa or does that say tempeh it says oh
it's Tempe yeah here we get a guy
I
I don't
I'm not where you know what I mean it
depends on where you're at and you're
out and like I wasn't talking about it
for so long that I couldn't really try
anything out until I was like uh that
makes sense 16 weeks when I started
talking about it on stage so I feel like
it's too soon for that yeah yeah
um I also feel like there's so many
specials and so much stuff coming out
that I'm like I really would like to
wait until no rush until it's good I
agree really good hey that's that's rare
now it's funny that that's like you're
in the minority who's the first one I'm
really gonna wait for a while yeah there
you go you know I always felt like too
much desperation you know to be selling
tickets but now it's like okay I can
like take a deep breath but uh yeah no
there's some there's too many specials
there's like gotta be like 1200 a year I
feel like I know and you ever post on
Instagram you're like I posted a clip
today look at me and then you start
scrolling down it's like clip clip clip
clip clip like damn this whole feed is
Clips yeah yeah it's I mean it's uh it's
a lot so I just kind of am like I'm I'm
trying to focus on my stand-up in the
way that I did earlier on where it was
like each joke mattered yes you know
what I mean
um I'm trying to really kind of focus up
on this it's good for you because a lot
of people just want the they want the
glory like oh I have a special can you
retweet me can you high five me yeah and
they don't actually care about the
material it doesn't seem like right yeah
good for you I mean there's plenty of
people who still do but I think that
they're yeah there's just a lot there's
a lot of pressure on Comics to put [__]
out and I kind of am like let me just so
much pressure let me just take some of
that off myself good yeah what do you
got Samo I know I got Portland Maine uh
New Hampshire where is that New
Hampshire I can't even see Hampton Beach
yeah I got National Target Connecticut
that's a casino I forgot the casino we
got uh Richmond Virginia
uh [__] always yeah Greensboro
Asheville Charlotte North Carolina yeah
Knoxville on the 8th yeah we got uh
Nashville Birmingham Memphis Memphis is
moving a little slow
comedy Market uh Nashville on pump Ford
that's gonna be great the Ryman guys and
uh oh wow what else Denver Paramount
Theater on June 22nd that's a great one
yeah that's two shows yeah on the 23rd
in Santa Fe 24th in San Antonio
yeah and then we got a few more added uh
yeah see on the roads it's gonna be
great hell yeah Houston's Gonna Be Cool
House of Blues oh yeah yeah that's fun
fun town Houston's a fun town for sure
it is all right I'm all over the place
this is like a LensCrafters ad
so I'm all over Australia check out the
website go to Australia I'm not going to
read every date and then um coming back
and announcing a theater tour special
comes out
July actually I'm not sure if I'm
supposed to say the date scratch that
special out in the summer later in the
summer we'll see on Netflix and make
sure to drink get some Bodega cat folks
it's online it's available at uh Bodega
cat
spirits.com it's also available at the
stores Texas California Kentucky Florida
and Pepto how about a sponsor Pepto we
got weak stomachs and we're drinking
throughout a podcast so hook us up
Heroes puking daily so she's like Kate
Moss over here
[Laughter]
love you guys thanks for listening thank
you Rosebud thank you as always for
having me check out whiskey fish yeah on
YouTube when we hope the the writers
strike uh resolves itself yeah but not
too soon back from Mexico news thank you
Salamanca and Peters as always and uh
keep keep listening yeah yeah praise
Ella thanks guys thank you
[Music]
Defender
Bender I've had a little much person and
Norman's talking [__] about the [__]
post and I get down in the same way
dangerous
[Music]
out to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]